[Music]
she felt that somebody had pressed
thumps into like when you strangle
someone that's what she remembers those
marks after like after thumps this is
part two of what happened to Annie and
use six part series from Sky News story
cast i'm lorna dugal previously in part
one nearly fifteen years after her
daughter's death Booya
Annie's mother has just been told by
Undertaker goon that she believes
markings on Annie's body are evidence of
murder and almost said the fear field
kind of Jenna girl feels that they know
that this is wrong there is something
very wrong about this and such a part to
in a nice story the case for murder
how will I explain to my husband that my
daughter our daughter was heavily beaten
up you don't get big bruises from out of
nothing it's June the 26th 2019 and the
case is about to take on a new dimension
mansion thought out who murdered her
vegetarian in 2005 Undertaker goon was
not the first person to raise concerns
over Annie's body it was removed it was
pulled off from Alice scope following
her discovery on the beach
Annie was taken to cross house hospital
in Kilmarnock where she remained for two
days before undergoing an autopsy
she was then driven to London by Harris
and two weeks after she was found on
preswick beach
Annie was fluent to Sweden and taken to
Donna B's funeral home the Soviet about
to viet in fact her body would lie here
for over a year before finally being
buried for ghoulia the critical point in
this journey is when Annie was driven to
London there were a funeral company in
London that were responsible for the
transportation and they made her ready
for the trip she had to be prepared for
the journey to be able to transport her
to Sweden because of Annie's insurance
policy she was flown to Sweden from
London but this company I just want to
read a letter that was sent by global
networks funeral assistance it was a
global networks funeral assistance when
producer Robert Mohan was recording in
Sweden with goon Annie's mother ghoulia
allowed Robert to read these letters so
the letter is dated prisoner date on the
letter but it says what regards the
above case I would like to offer a full
explanation for the events that took
place but operations director Damien
Melville was so troubled by the deep
bruisings he saw he wrote this letter to
Annie's insurance company and notified
the Scottish police during the
restoration of Annie's hair in
particular he found that her hair was
falling out you too washing and call me
I can verify that she did have
significant bruising to her body which
for reasons I cannot explain I believe
were not included in the autopsy report
I find this to be quite unusual
considering the circumstances of her
death and I recommend a contact with the
hospital coroner in this respect at
first the police said the marks were a
result of exposure and decomposition but
these were not the
kind of marks these were bruises they
also explained that Annie had come into
contact with rocks on the seabed could
it be the case that the bruising was
caused by Annie's body being in Rothsay
water and being bounced off stones or
rocks but none of this made sense to
Annie's best friend Maria when she
visited Prestwick Beach she saw that the
sand was course but the water seemed
gentle and clear of any large rocks an
Annie could only have been in the sea a
maximum of 15 hours the brew sinks and
the marks is not consistent with Annie
walking out in the water drowning
herself and then floating back to the
shore
besides Maria always thought bruising
couldn't happen after death
after leaving goons funeral home in 2005
Anna's mother googa and best friend
Maria went in search of Ali's autopsy
reports we too had questions
so in July
2019 we met with dr. Stuart Hamilton a
forensic pathologist with the British
Home Office and asked if he could take a
look at Annie's autopsy the way it's
written it goes through exactly as I
would expect a report to be written he
began reading the report and everything
appears to check out there is no
definitive finding there is no one thing
that says that this person did drown but
then we have what for me is a very
interesting comment white clear frothy
fluid is present coming from the mouth
now that is something that points to
drowning but what about the explanation
as to how and when bruising on Annie's
body came about bruising is something
that happens when you get blunt trauma
when you're alive that is I think the
most concerning aspect of this whole
thing so the first explanation that
could be proffered is this young woman
has significant bruising therefore she
has significant blunt trauma in life
this has been missed up to this point
that is one interpretation that is a
very very concerning one that means
there is something going on here that's
simply not been considered dr. Hamilton
is a highly qualified home office
pathologist if what he says is true
bruising could only have happened before
Annie drowned because somebody has
drowned doesn't mean of necessity that
the only thing that has happened is they
drowned is it possible that she came to
harm before to answer this question dr.
Hamilton would need the photos of
Annie's autopsy
but when we ask the Crone office if we
could see them they wrote back to us
saying it wasn't in the public interest
for these photos to be released the key
question for us is why why don't
leckrone office see this as a matter of
public interest nearly 12 years ago
Annie's family were also refused access
but back then they gave her a very
different answer to the same question
doing so they said might jeopardize some
future investigation we're beginning to
see why Annie's family have serious
questions over the circumstances of her
death is somebody somewhere trying to
hide something
Guga has asked this question many times
in the Swedish media after 14 years she
would eventually grow exhausted however
in 2014 she spoke with great clarity in
a phone interview with red ice
productions do you know how the Scottish
police went about we're going to use
some parts of that interview to help
tell this story and how quickly did they
come to their conclusions about that
this was a suicide they told me every
day every day for six for about six
weeks that my daughter had committed a
suicide so to begin with I could say
something about where she was found on
them she was found about 80 kilometres
away from where she lived them she lived
in Edinburgh but was found in Prestwich
and a small community where where the
airport is situated on and she was found
in a walking distance from the airport
Ormond Beach and it was a strong swimmer
and this was the fourth of December and
when she was found her jacket and her
bag was beside her on the beach so that
was those
how Annie's body along with her jacket
and bag all ended up in the exact same
location seems really odd but it's not
the only odd thing though police had
recovered Annie's wallet
Undertaker gun found Annie's credit
cards under the mattress of her
transport coffin while the clothes she'd
been waiting on the beach had been sent
home to the family still wet and where
were the rest of her things she was
wearing a red and white fleece but
that's missing that's not found been
found for gu yeah it was beginning to
feel that the police had been less than
meticulous at the crime scene
[Music]
our understanding is that the police did
not treat this as a crime scene because
in their eyes no crime had taken place
within a few months of Annie's death
gulia set out on her own to find out
what happened to Annie she flew to
Scotland to try and find the last person
reputed to have seen Arnie alive and we
are about to meet that man - it's late
july 2019 in preswick and under
Montgomery is walking along the beach
where Annie was found dead he's done
this walk hundreds of times but when he
left home in the Saturday Annie was last
seen with his friend Doug Parker he
didn't know just how significant this
walk would become and that time of year
there was a kind of messiness on the
water
we call it the gloom in and Scotland it
says at dusk the light wasn't perfect by
any means but it must have been earlier
than the police maintain that as the Sun
was going down around 4:00 p.m. that
Saturday December the 3rd 2005 and he
was filmed on CCTV around half a mile
away by the town but on the beach there
was someone out about 100 meters by the
water I can't even tell you what was
strange about there but it was
noticeable and we stopped and and worked
for a little while then we walked or
great room to where the houses are and
then we came by period of time I would
say maybe 50 me or
minutes doesn't take very long to walk
the head lane headlines and come back
again and as we came by lady was still
there and I'm just thinking seeing a
lady I think it was a lady but the state
of the light and the distance away I
can't be absolutely sure given Andrew
couldn't see with any certainty that
this was Annie or even a woman standing
at the water's edge how would the Crown
Office able to see saw especially given
that the police say Andrew was the sole
witness this is an outtake from a letter
written by a senior Scottish politician
to the Swedish government in 2007 a
witness statement indicated someone
fitting her description was seen
standing at the water's edge looking out
to sea at about 1630 are Annie's mother
GU you know beliefs
this letter is proof the authorities
were using evidence that wasn't entirely
clear either that or it was Andrews
friend dunk who'd identified army the
police ever questioned dog I know I did
call him to say that the police mate to
do but I don't I I can't remember ever
going back to I see the whole thing just
seemed to drop to find out for sure
we called dog at his home in England why
a dog it's Rommel Hearn and sky I've
been chatting down to a few times and I
asked him could he contact you on my
behalf and I thought any I can't add
anything to what Andrews told you I
really can't you know or both walking on
the beach which is very afternoon and
so the figure about 150 yards away it
was a bit indistinct because of
complexity great afternoon
visibility wasn't all good and that's
right okay say and we continued see
whether it was a woman or what person
and when you were speaking to the police
what did and well Andrew spoke to the
police he definitely remembers and he
was called to it was an air police
station or another plantation nothing we
left the day after we saw this person on
the beach
sure literally I met my wife and I but
you don't you don't recall getting any
phone calls from the police the police
would have known there were two key
witnesses why did the interview only one
in the days after
Arnie's death could one of these
witnesses have sparked a memory if they
were interviewed alone or together we'll
never know
in 2007 Annie's family weren't aware of
any of this bus already their
relationship with the Scottish
authorities had broken down but home
many mothers and families from abroad
call that urgently that I did and asked
all those questions why was I not taken
seriously deeply they want to shame
didn't that they not fear that they
would shame them themselves not taking
Anna's case seriously or did did not
matter because she want was not the
Scottish girl or was i annoying them in
some way should as should a woman a
Scottish woman would she keep silent in
in in this situation was I serious
behaving strangely mothers do
mothers should cry at the graveyard but
they should not ask questions or did
they make a mistake and I do not want to
admit it so that's why they keep to this
story all the time no matter what I say
no matter no matter what we present
however by now the Scottish authorities
were coming under some pressure because
around this time the Swedish Minister
for Foreign Affairs and one-time prime
minister Carl Bildt called for Annie's
case to be re-examined the response was
not to reopen the case but to invite the
Swedish crime inspector hands Malanda
over to Scotland and I'm not sure that
he was allowed to sit down and have a
look himself at in the investigation
I think the Scottish police read parts
of the investigation because when Hans
Melander left his left us a copy of his
visit in Scotland
it was very it didn't cover to us it
didn't cover everything it may not have
covered everything but this visits
supercharged athili this Annie had been
murdered the information felt even more
significant because the police and
Scotland had up until this point kept it
from the family but why
detective Melander has declined to talk
to us he never gave a reason but the
family say he gave them the exact
location on the beach
Annie was found and this is where we
need to slow the pace for just a moment
because when you walk south along the
shore and preswick the beach Rises
slightly you never notice but what it
means is the tide doesn't always reach
the seawall on the raised end of the
beach where Annie was discovered every
time we had been at the beach we have we
have tried to speak with people who have
been willing to speak with us and some
were were concerned about the fact that
that happens that the tide can't
transport the body to the place where
Annie was found and his body was found
so this has been something that we have
wanted to to receive some proof about
they went to the site exactly the same
tide that Annie was found washed up this
is Tom Minogue a Scottish political
activists who's taken a keen interest in
Annie's case I'm caught near that with
them and with a mayor office at that
time the water where she was found right
up against the key wall wouldn't have
floated a body there and there's always
the possibility that somebody can be
murdered in a scene away from them
they've seen me at the body is found and
yes people can be turned in the bath and
then brought and laid on the shore that
was something that Gucci and and Maria
considered according to one marine
expert we've spoken to
preswick did experience a higher tide
than usual that weekend high enough in
theory for Annie to have ended up by the
seawall where she was found but because
it's impossible to say so definitively
the family say the theory Annie was
killed and placed on the beach cannot be
discounted and there was more I have a
document somewhere routing there is a
DNA on her hands from an unknown woman
sources close to the Scottish and
Swedish police have confirmed that DNA
from an unknown woman was indeed
discovered on Annie's hands both
suggested Annie might have picked up the
DNA after touching something like a
handrail for instance as opposed to some
direct physical contact it was found
somewhere on the Anna's hands we don't
know exactly where and even though she
had been in what in this salt water it
was still there and we asked them to
match it again and we had quite a email
conversation with with the Crown Office
about that and they didn't want to test
it again but why didn't the Crown Office
want to test what sounded like crucial
evidence and why did the Scottish
authorities ignore calls from one of the
most powerful politicians in Sweden to
look again at the circumstances
surrounding Annie's death
we should say at this point if you
happen to be in preswick on the weekend
of Saturday December the 4th 2005 if you
saw something unusual on the beach that
day something that appeared odd or out
of place then please email us story cast
at Sky News Co UK
[Music]